quand on a vu passer ce tweet des
toilettes qui demande de s'inscrire sur
internet
on s'est dit personne n'était à l'abri
des fausses nouvelles tout ça c'est pour
les décrypteurs men on avait tous terrés
là on a un côté de la billetterie du
centre bell gare lucien l'allier c'est
un des lieux des centres névralgiques du
transport en commun de montréal
vous voulez aller aux toilettes non
l'accès aux toilettes il faut remplir un
formulaire en ligne
il faut entrer sa carte opus c'est ce
qu'on a fait j'ai rentré ma carte opus
ya à peu près deux heures parce que ça
va marcher n'ont pas le droit d'aller
aux toilettes
c'est ce formulaire qu'il faut remplir
et le site indique que ça peut prendre
cinq jours avant d'avoir l'accès ça n'a
pas de bon sens vous aviez pas d'autre
endroit responsable et ce qu'ils veulent
pas nettoyé et il n'y a pas de toilettes
dans tous les trains qui arrivent ici
souvent quand j'aime voyager avec mon
paquet un peu plus âgé donc il vient pas
souvent montréal qu'il soit besoin de la
chambre de ben oui c'est pas quelqu'un
comme lui c'est vraiment inconvénients
surtout que s'il faut attendre cinq
jours avant qu'on peut avoir accès c'est
trop tendre
en fait c'est le canadien pacifique le
propriétaire des lieux qui a demandé à
exode de fermer les toilettes pour des
raisons de sécurité et exo a trouvé
cette solution l'état vit une soirée ou
un inspecteur a retrouvé une vingtaine
de seringue souillée sur le plancher et
xav est conscient que c'est une
situation exceptionnelle qui est idéal
pour les gens qui utilisent la gare
lucien l'allier et c'est pourquoi cette
solution là est temporaire et des idées
pour une solution permanente
les usagers en on devrait être un
service central et avant une clé qu'on
va demander pour la clé à la porte
peaches et saucisses une question
sécurité ou s'inspirer de montréal qui a
commencé l'année dernière à installer
des toilettes publiques autonettoyantes
et gratuite ici mathieu prost radio
canada mon rêve